[Music]
one look into the annals of
counter-strike history and you're
greeted by an army of super teams
collections of talent so impressive so
insurmountable that they just had to win
they're the champions again sk esl one
but hidden beneath these ultra talented
giants the phase clans and astralis of
the world is one ever constant
what it means force them the holy
chalice now belongs to team liquid the
hope of an entire continent one
world-class rifling machine whose
presence remains unwavering while the
game's giants walk in and out of
this is the story of north america's
hero the player who helped build the
greatest team in the region's history
only to burn it down and do it again
the only constant in a sea of change
that's right the only thing going from
one more headshot they're gonna try to
oh
god
elise
coming up from long instead he sprays
down to elise gonna put it into a quad
kill now he's gonna try and charge me
wrong and that's the eight oh my god at
least this is the story of a liege
[Music]
despite being known today as one of the
world's best cs go riflers jonathan
elise jablinowski didn't start out by
playing shooters elise grew up watching
his brother play rts games on the family
computer specifically age of empires and
starcraft by the age of four fights
between the two boys over whose turn it
was to use the computer caused the
family to buy a liege his own setup and
that's where his dream took hold see
among his peers today elish is a rare
case he's somebody who knew he wanted to
get into esports long before it felt
like a serious option when he was eight
elish told his taekwondo instructor that
he had no backup plan in life besides
gaming and i said all right johnny jabs
what do you want to be when you get
older you know what do you want to do so
he said i'm going to be a gamer
so i said to him i'm like well what's
your plan b what's what else you know
why don't you pick something else just
in case he says oh no sir and he points
at a sign on a wall that i have that
says winners never quit quitters never
win
and he goes no no that's it that's all i
want to be
i saw all the other pro players back
then about how they were able to travel
around the world and i just thought that
i would be able to do that and i i
thought that i had the skill elijah's
first taste of real competitive play
actually came in 2013 through the
starcraft 2 world championship series
when he played at an american season 2
qualifier event and lost a best of three
to select a player who elijah actually
named himself after elige literally
meaning select in spanish
while starcraft was his love at the time
elish kindled a new romance behind the
scenes one with counter-strike for years
elish had played cs 1.6 but never saw it
as an esports option that could compete
at the same level as starcraft but
everything changed when cs go came out
and elise realized that his rts skills
weren't totally useless
anger does finally go in the site but
aliga still gets the frag and he'll work
his way in and he'll definitely get this
bomb plant but uh volcano and yellow are
going to be going ahead and running
their stuff in here yeah with a little
hp oligarch catches the headshot there
and so we could see yet another clutchy
on this map if you can take out
volcanoes and he does great flash ping
placement great movement there from liga
as well when i went from starcraft 2 to
cs go i actually think there was a lot
of skills that transferred over and i
think the main one is just learning how
to learn aircraft 2 is a very individual
game it's a 1v1 game and when you lose
it's only yourself to blame and you just
have to figure out the most efficient
way possible to do things over the next
year and a half ali switched his focus
from starcraft to cs go and very quickly
started getting offers from teams at the
forefront of which was team liquid
and he was so young and already so good
generally speaking we love to take those
shots and take those opportunities to
try and see if we can develop a talent
into a superstar for liquid it was an
easy choice elish was a burgeoning young
talent with massive potential and for a
liege it was even easier when i joined
liquid i thought it was amazing because
i obviously came from starcraft and they
were an organization that i really
looked up to they're this elite level
counter-strike uh team that i'm gonna be
on elise signed to liquid in march of
2015 and things looked great he was part
of a bigger play by the team to build an
n a super team and it seemed like they
might be able to pull it off and now
it's going to be between elige and the
remaining three vertice pro members
elise nice headshot to start a second
one as well
it's gonna be now him versus neo the
legend bomb planted for neo as well and
he gives away his position but this is
just fantastic it's all on the legion he
knows the um he hasn't been able to
upgrade it whatsoever he's got a toy
with the native ep at long range so just
hiding behind this pillar this is
crucial but a nice shot onto taz from
long range
oh my eddie actually clutches it with an
smg by 2016 liquid had scrapped most of
its original roster keeping only a liege
nitro and adren while adding hiko and an
up-and-coming ukrainian talent named
simple to the lineup simple was coming
off an esl ban and was a young phenom
still looking for a team to set his feet
with at the time but he also had a
reputation prior to joining liquid for
[ __ ] talking and a penchant for angry
outbursts toward team members and his
opponents
thank you for game dumas
thank you really nice to play with you
you're playing like [ __ ] [ __ ]
nice simple man
i think in general his skill outweighs
his attitude but alongside a liege in
liquid simple gotten opportunity and as
the team start to threaten the scene's
powerhouses elijah's rifling was a
critical part of their success and
olofmeister and the rest speeding up
that work on b this kind of trying to
see if they can work on a as well elise
getting a counter headshot getting a
second kill could he get a third as well
nitro has gone down already at least
doing massive work up on the catwalk
flusher coming up from long instead he
sprays down to elise gonna put it into a
quad kill now one more kill for the ace
and it's one on two one
liquid oh he gets the jump in and now
elise knows where he is for jw back for
the smoke i don't even know what level
of counter strike this is he fakes the
bomb once jw got a chance if he could
walk out he's very low on health leash
on the other side grenade gonna be going
in and unleash is he going to try and
charge me wrong so that's the h oh my
god elise acing fnatic in the 25th round
these were also huge moments for elise
personally for the first time in his
career he was going toe-to-toe with the
very best teams in the world on paper it
should have been incredible
but the reality was different
because behind the scenes elysian simple
didn't always see eye to eye it wasn't
really anything about like having two
star players i think that it was just a
very obvious personality conflicts
within the team throughout the whole
team
to be completely honest throughout the
whole team
so it was very tough and i think that
changes need to happen and we
we had to do them just straight up elise
has since acknowledged his contribution
to the toxic environment at the time but
he's also fired back at claims that he
was the wedge that drove simple out of
the team during the time when simple and
i were teammates i think that the whole
time period was kind of blown out of
proportion a little bit where i got
scapegoated and i think that the whole
team felt the way that i did but i was
just the one that was kind of saying it
for the team after only four months the
pairing between the two young stars came
to an end the last event where elise
played alongside simple was esl one
cologne 2016 and yet again team liquid
showed that they belonged among the
world's best alicia alone now versus
three you know it's got a high sense
that's a nice two-man spray down where's
the last man doesn't know he has enough
bullets that is an unbelievable clutch
there for a lead maybe it might be
enough if at least we can get two frames
here he can let's
make that three and leave the top spot
on the beast fight for liquid look over
the full spring
first as well
actually picks him up going for the
third gets the bomber as well
elise doesn't seem played by the big
scene stage so far they do get a plan
a little bit of money but eliza's been
absolutely sick in these last two rounds
amazing stuff and even though they
didn't win at all they went far deeper
than most expected
that is the performance of their lives
and not let's not forget some of the
absolutely absurd scientifically
improbable clutches before they're
simple with the options flying down on
the beep on side no scope required that
elise stepping up in this series he
played some big boy counter-strike
tonight because you might not see it in
the scoreboard he might not have had the
most frags but whenever they needed it
when they're down 13-11 and they haven't
won a single round he's the one getting
the kills uh just absolutely incredible
clutch performance from him at the time
this level of international success was
huge for american counter-strike and it
showed that liquid's big play to
assemble top tier talent could work in
the region but even after simple left
the team there were problems this time
with elish whose behavior was brought
into question i think elige when he
first got to the team had it pretty
rough
he's a perfectionist and he's the kind
of guy that he works utterly hard and he
studies and reviews and you could go
over something once with john in two
minutes and he's got it and there's
players that might need to go over it 10
times and they still might not get it
like simple elise was not much of a
people person he had the skill he had
the chops he had the intuition
all of that was spot on but
he lacked in some of the interpersonal
dynamics and
the teamwork that was required in order
for
there to be performance of the team not
him as an individual and some of that
developed over time elige knew he was in
hot water but he also knew that he
wanted to change and so he pledged to do
better i ended up like just like
messaging them again and just being like
guys like i am going to do like whatever
it takes i know that i messed up a lot
but i'm going to you know work on my
problems and fix everything that i can
so i can i can be the teammate that you
guys want to play with
things eventually cool down for liquid
going forward and over the next two
years the team rebuilt itself into an
absolute juggernaut by 2019 they had a
new powerhouse roster keeping a liege
and nitro while adding stewie2k twists
and naf besides the new framework liquid
also brought with them a renewed energy
what the team's management said was
largely due to a liege and the personal
work he had done on himself when we
started to see the success from the
counter-strike team
that was a result of i think a
progression in the mindset for john
where
he started to put importance on the
relationship that he had with his
teammates seeing that development over
time for john is kind of when
the performance of the team was unlocked
and
that's where so much of our success was
cemented by john's journey
through the team and right out of the
gate this new liquid screamed success
snatching first place at the eye by
power masters from the best team on
planet earth astralis
so he's able to get some cover and he's
been great here as long as he can hold
tight to the pillar he's gotten the
second one nap will fall back into the
pit and he'll take a second one as well
that's it
neff seals the deal although there were
a few hiccups by the summer liquid ran
rampant winning pretty much every big
tournament there was their victims were
numerous fnatic at the intel xtreme
masters in sydney he's got the c set and
he's gone it's all on the jw smoked away
and it's done finally
liquid get their notch on the grand slam
ends at dreamhack in dallas he consents
players on the other side it's gonna be
a kill for twist surely he gets the
first is this where it ends aloe in the
three verses one
but he's got the kill
and liquid habit they've got the
championship they've got masters
and two in the intel grand slam
g2 at the esl pro league finals in
montpellier
an absolute disaster stewie he may have
just done it
double for him and alicia on the other
side oh my god eminek get a one versus
three with 19 seconds
unbelievable scenes here ladies and
gentlemen team liquid are your season
nine pro league champions
throughout liquid's summer onslaught
elish was consistently the unofficial
mvp of the team he was also ranked the
fourth best player in the world by hltv
that year and many attribute that to two
things the first being his monstrous
proficiency with the krieg which many
considered to be extremely overpowered
at the time and the second being his
amazing skills as a rifler see rifling
is a fundamental counter-strike skill
for many it's like breathing but for a
very select number of players it was an
art form and a liege was picasso
he's committed and his team was backing
out now they realize they need to get
closer
no they don't tiles can do it all
himself better still finds the headshot
lineup potential though and a leash he's
put them in overtime and he gets 35
kills in regulation to do it
unbelievable scenes elite what a hero he
has been unlike other shooters where
spray patterns are often random cs
sprays can be controlled
study a gun spray pattern enough and you
can fire at fully automatic speeds while
maintaining surgical accuracy i do think
that spraying is the one thing that is
able to be mastered i think that is very
consistent there is a little bit of rng
to the game but it is something that can
be mastered and i'm really proud of that
to be able to say that i i have one of
the best phrase if not the best gray in
the game uh so i think that it is
masterable and i think that anyone uh
can't deal with enough practice and with
practice and penance elige and liquid
had finally arrived the cathedral of
counter-strike
every person in this
[Applause]
if liquid won esl one cologne in 2019
they would win the crown jewel the intel
grand slam a one million dollar grand
prize given out to any team that could
secure four wins at top tier dream hack
or esl tournaments in a consecutive ten
event window team vitality on the other
hand who would be playing liquid had a
strong team with zyewu at its helm
excuse me at least rather in nitro and
walking over to a where they'll be found
by xy with great hold and taiwu to get
the bomb back again we said double
overtime isn't out of possibility isn't
unbelievably impossible but it might be
with finally hitting shots like that as
he steps back into the door anyone plans
there's no rush slow it down as now
confirms the second map for vitality but
as much as the french challengers
resisted elysian liquid refused to be
denied zai will get stewie elish with
the mp9s remember we talked about them
twist oh turn it around he somehow gets
the lineup on two they had the advantage
on him and elise strikes back a couple
of kits available but it looks like they
could have a massive advantage at least
not missing many shots now that's apex
hitting the deck nbk with the orb not
the ideal weapon as soon as you miss one
they're gonna jump on top of you just
like that rpk's been fantastic
throughout but he can't find the shots
this time it's liquid with 14 they tied
things up if it's rpk this drop they
could be in serious trouble that should
do it there we go it's team liquid and
that's what it means to them they've
taken it at the fourth map the favorites
coming into the tournament have just
unlocked the intel grand slam at esl one
cologne underneath and a million dollar
bonus
people were screaming and yelling usa
and the bodyguards that they had and
people are trying to touch them
i
still was surprised that like this is
this is my kid after the grand slam
liquid immediately took two more first
place titles at blast pro series los
angeles
and iem chicago
it looked like 2019 was all but in the
bag for liquid
and then
well
they took a break
as they returned from the break in time
for the berlin major it was unclear
exactly what liquid's level of play
would be
and fans didn't have to wait too long to
find out in this battle two very close
quarters he's gonna have an opportunity
to understand they've done it and
they've done it without seeing liquid
find 10. but here comes the defuse in
the smoke can they find it with the
spray going close sanji getting the
clock out he's going to close vanguard
i've done it they've actually managed
they've managed to take down team liquid
in the best of one they've given liquid
a one-two start at the new legends phase
i uh that is absolutely unbelievable and
even though they managed to fight their
way into the brackets their first
opponent was
familiar this is such a problem i think
that's exactly what's going to happen
here there it is shutting her back and
astralis again proving that they are the
greatest of all time james
the arch enemy liquid had once conquered
had risen again
astralis had taken the berlin major
which should have been liquids major and
they were pissed
and then at the blast global finals
astralis dealt liquid a second
deafening defeat and device already
wanting to come in through mini an
excellent flash zip x takes him down
it's all on naf
ice in his veins can he handle this heat
bomb is tap not planted for him he's got
it down to the 1v1 zip x could very well
clutch this if he sticks it no way
[Applause]
incredible
16-12 a stunning fashion to win and just
like that team liquid's incredible
summer run was over
between their glorious grand slam in the
present day liquid's performance has
careened all over the place some
attribute liquids declined to the
departure of key team members like nitro
and twists who left in august of 2020 in
january 2021 respectively others just
say their run was a lucky fluke but
elish isn't worried he believes liquid
will rise again
that's something that was always really
cool to me about our grand slam win was
that we were just beating random teams
we weren't just winning small events we
were winning big events against the best
teams in the world and we finished it
off at cologne where all of the best
teams in the world were there so it's
incredible for me to look back at that
and be like okay this was not a fluke
there's no doubt about it we were good
going forward elysian liquid are looking
to a summer of major competitions and
are aiming to get proper revenge against
astralis for their 2019 comeback elish
even hopes that one day perhaps team
liquid will be the new astralis
and when i look at what we can do
forward there's still so much room that
we can do we only won for a couple
months i want to be as dominant as
astralis where
you know you're the best team in the
world you've won for years i still think
that you can always just improve as much
as possible and i do think that my
ceiling is just going to keep going
higher i think i'm still very young i'm
only 23 right now that is not even close
to being old i think that i can only
just keep getting better
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite size videos you won't find anywhere
else hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages
[Music]